u.s. religious history and the
department's name
history Finity here and i'm going to
lead off just by introducing our first
speaker who historic school and georgian
paper and pretending to the therapy
which 19th century philosophy and
theology again we have two speakers each
will speak for about 25 minutes and then
unfortunately i'm wholly inadequate job
relatives in history counts and more so
just to begin george by Cooler who is
for 1966 if you germany through grades
israel in 1998 because ma a medieval
jewish philosophy of 2006 and 2010 his
PhD from University he had a post
doctoral fellowship at the good -
university of frankfurt in 2011 and
since 2012 he's been a senior lecturer
at the department of jewish he has
published in 2012 reading Maimonides
philosophy in 19th century Germany and
in 2013 he published Jewish mechanism in
the age of emancipation
reinterpretations between technological
socialism
this research interests range from
modern Jewish philosophy 19th century
theology jewish-christian relations
Germany between thank you very much for
this lovely introduction what I refer to
as supersessionism is what you just
called replacement Theory theology this
is the same thing it's called
substitution theory replacement whatever
but this is the same actually the same
idea and I'm not talking about all the
Jewish Christian debates in this period
but only of one and this I think it's
the most famous one it's the debate
around a pamphlet of the German
philosopher Bruno Bauer Newton Fraga
published in 1842 this debate became
famous not because of our subject today
but because Karl Marx you know wrote his
famous anti-semitic maybe pamphlet
against power as a review of powers
writings and this is how the Bruno Bauer
debate became famous I don't want to
focus on this issue not on a political
side of it but only theological side of
it so most of the reactions to power the
political were about the question why
Bauer is against granting the Jews
emancipation but his arguments the
arguments used in making this point is
the arguments are rather theological and
what is generally overlooked in research
is that there is a long list of Jewish
respondents to boon Obama who of course
argue on the theological level against
this modern version secularized version
of supersession theory that Bauer's
presenting and and this is what I this
is the nice thing about 19th century
what this panel is about that we have
for the first time until now we have
heard all the bad things that Gentiles
or the author of John whoever goes you
know say about Jews and now we hear I
mean I'm trying to present what Jews
have to
and not in a polemical way not from my
point of view not from a Jewish point of
view but you know in a very
philosophical theological way this is
probably the first time the Jews argue
back on this on these on these questions
and this is what I like about 19th
century so I will in the first part of
my paper present a short summary of what
power has written in his famous pamphlet
Daehyun flogger
from 1842 and in the second part I will
refer to three Jewish reactions to law
so as I said rabbis responding to bar
cannot ignore the theological arguments
at power actually mentions in this work
interesting is that what power presents
on the field of religion is to a great
extent a galleon that is a secularized
version of this old Christian theology
of supersessionism that again is the
theory that Christianity not only
replaced Judaism historically but also
substituted all that was once a huge
contribution to religious progress and
culture with its own values and that's
made Judaism obsolete futile expendable
whatever you call so what is interesting
about the Jewish reactions is that the
Jewish respondents the Jewish the rabbis
that reacted to Bauer where most of them
were Hegelian thinkers themselves so
they meet on this common ground in fact
and that makes their apparently
self-evident rejection of Christians
super session session ISM even more
interesting the Jewish theologians are
forced by power to provide counter
arguments for justification of Jewish
existence in history that is to prove
what contributions Judaism chosen made
and is still able to make to world
civilization culture independent of
Christianity so this this is the
challenge in fact and this is probably
as I said the first time the Jewish
voices formulate serious theories about
place and meaning of true
within the development of universal
religious thought and that's something
like a starting point along a folk for
modern Jewish philosophy so power
argument is surprisingly sophisticated
and challenging for an outright
anti-semitic pamphlet it operates with
the classical supersessionism of the
church but in a very modernized and
highly intellectualized version of
Hegel's philosophy of historical
development power was at the time of his
writing still left to Gillian but strong
atheist tendencies he had been deprived
of his authorization to teach theology
at Prussian universities earlier the
same year this pamphlet was published
both for his naturalist readings of the
gospel of all the Gospels and for his
atheist rationalistic way of teaching
Protestant priests having broken with
Marx and communism already the year
earlier and 41 Bauer remained for the
time from the writing of the pamphlet
until the end of his life rather than
ARCIC alien critic of Christianity as
well as of Judaism whose influence on
Christian theology he radically tried to
diminish throughout his life in the
Galleon gap the old Christian
substitution theory assumed a new much
more drastic form by for st. Augustine
there was still a rational explanation
even if it's not a very flattering one
for the further existence of the Jews
under Hegelian dialectics the older
parts of the historical contradiction
were completely dissolved in history
with the victorious emergence of the
synthesis applied by Bauer to religion
it was Christianity who contradicted
Judaism and does robbed it of its right
to exist while in the end both religions
Judaism and Christianity was superseded
by the philosophical principle of an
almost an atheistic pantheism in
bora-bora demonstrated us for several
theological note notions that I want to
go into it for some strange reason Bauer
expressed his super specialist model
still in the old metaphor of mother and
daughter
religion that you might probably know
kasaya in Judaism it is not the daughter
who is unappreciative of the mother
claims power but the mother refused to
acknowledge her daughter after the
daughter has understood and further
advance the legacy of the mother both
cannot exist next to each other anymore
this is how power concluded in his Hague
alien way and insulated okay in the
Atheist synthesis both religions so what
power in fact accuses Jewish theology of
is that it does not follow Hegel Judaism
insisted on an historical authority of
its law and thus on the meta historical
existence of itself as a people the
reason for the stubborn Jewish
incapacity for historical development
was thus easily identified in the header
enormous source of the law itself which
is traced by Bauer to its oriental
origin the old Israelite he says has not
yet acquired the consciousness that he
is a free agent and the rational being
and therefore he still regards the
observance of meaningless ceremonies as
his noble task it Arana me is important
both for Spinoza as you probably know
and also for Hegel in their explanation
of Judaism as outdated the Jews neither
live their own lives nor accomplish
their own actions by definition that you
is never motivated by his own will this
is the purpose of the legend of the
divinity of the law in a Jewish view and
this view the law assumes in eternal our
historical truth value for power as it
was for Hegel before him truth have a
relative value only they appear and
disappear in the course of history
making way for the ultimate truth which
is the truth of perpetual criticism of
source of course or truth arrived at
through criticism in Hegel and involved
in my view this is a really good
opportunity to realize why more than
Jewish thought was always more drawn to
can't
philosophy Dan - hey Gillian philosophy
one point power admits that he fails
completely to understand the internal
logic of a very central demand of Jewish
theology that is the imitatio Dei the
imitation of God expressed in the famous
words that you all know from Leviticus
you receive to yuki-onna Kadosh be holy
because I am holy for power the
consequence does not follow from the
premises in this verse hello for Judaism
however this is me talking up the
transcendent immaterial God represents
exactly this eternal but ultimately
indiscernible truth value imitation of
God does means rather an infinite search
for God this is the challenge that
bauer's Jewish opponents have to cope
with in their attempts to reject his
philosophical anti-semitism after all
the debate took place in 43 year after
the publication of the pamphlet of bar
so this is long before content
philosophy was reintroduced into German
cata philosophy at German universities
which happens only in second half of the
19th century so this is ensured summary
power pamphlet the first Jewish thinker
who replied in detail to bars attacks on
Judaism was clearly a galleon
philosopher himself and therefore trying
to beat power on his own game Samuel
Hirsch third of him was at the time of
the office writing against Behar the
rabbi of the Grand Duchy of Luxembourg
published in 1848 his major work a 500
pages fast-breaking philosophical
analysis in my view of Judaism form a
largely Hegelian viewpoint the work that
to this day I guess is really
underestimated it's the beginning of
also of Jewish analysis of New Testament
in a very professional like interesting
in 43 Hirsch wrote a book Lang's refusal
of power reiterating many of his basic
assessments concerning the history and
the tenants of Jewish thought for hooch
Judaism is founded on general ethical
principle is a reformed rabbi except for
being a philosophies reformed rabbi it's
not founded on law but on general
ethical principles and those principles
that he calls the pillars of pure purest
morality are at the same time of eternal
value and part of a historical
development it is exactly there are
historical unchangeable a priori truth
that turned those basic teachings of
Judaism into what Hirsch calls the only
driving force of all history to date so
when her stars implicitly demonstrated
the importance of Judaism for historical
progress he refuted at the same time the
claim of heteronomy of Jewish law which
says it was exactly Paul's mistake not
Judaism it was Paul's mistake to
translate the word to LA with normos
with law okay this is nothing I have
nothing to do with Judaism and in whose
view and interestingly this is an
argument that he introduced first in 43
and you find this in every subsequent
Jewish theologian until the 20th century
they all say this is it all began with
the wrong translation of toga which in
the original Hebrew as you might all
know means teaching leader in German in
the earth and not though and not
something static and seen as an ongoing
process of learning and thus adapting
reality toga is no longer the expression
of an arbitrary divine will in Judaism
that is foreign to man rather the true
understanding of the will of God is that
man lives according to what is essential
to humanity therefore Hirsch concluded
the Jew who carries ours out God's will
is in fact carries out only his own
January world
end of quote the internal logic of the
human imitation of God is to be found in
man's like
to God according to the Bible to a God
who presents the very essence of
humanity powers view of holiness which
made him eject the notion of a Matar Zod
is inconsistent in his words it's simply
the contrived holiness of Christianity a
monkish holiness as host right which is
directly opposed to the Jewish idea
holiness that must be realized in the
midst of true life here below Hirsch tan
developed a very sophisticated highly
interesting counter history to Bauer
supersession as views on Judaism that I
can outline only very briefly here the
coming of Christ this is the shared
opinion of power and the church
substitution theology had a double
meaning on the one hand demonstrated
that the to deduce their own futility
the idea the futility of their idea that
to fulfill God's law for food God's will
by keeping what they believed was God's
law okay
on the other hand Christ shows the way
out of this dilemma salvation comes
through faith alone because nature is
inherently sinful all this is wrong
Judaism protest search believes in the
purity of nature that man is guiltless
of illness and death and is not indeed
indeed whereas it's not only is
absolutely you know yeah you have you do
saying this Judaism is not in need of a
redeemer the consequence of this concern
about contradiction between the two
religions is that power as a Hague alien
philosopher must deny as he really does
that Jesus has ever existed more than
Jewish theology on the other hand who's
continues accepts the historical Jesus
not the miracle maker of course but the
historical Jesus as a true consequence
of Judaism as a Jewish gift to the world
for her Jew
I quote is the classical expression of
monotheism and therefore the classical
expression of mankind and of both
while Jews wear anything but detached
from the cultural progress of humanity
in the time that followed Jesus as Power
had claimed famously her admitted that
they still could not build a godly God
capella Sh in German world on earth as
he said because they were just lacking
the political power to do so therefore
they often retreated to Talmud study as
the only dignified intellectual activity
left for them during the dark times of
the Middle Ages on the Christian side
only Martin Luther revitalized the true
spirit of Christ according to her she
which grew right out of Jewish sources
when Luther thought it is the mundane
does very sure and German that can and
should be holy
there's modern idea led to the
establishment of the Christian State
which is considered by Hirsch in the
wake of Hegel obviously to be the
greatest establishment the greatest
accomplishment of Protestantism other
than he however Hirsch believed the
modern Christian state represents
exactly this ancient Jewish notion of
the sanctification of this worldly life
that the Christian Reformation has
rediscovered a state of this nature the
political expression of holiness can and
must want the juice emancipation as
observant Jews it was Judaism which made
the state possible because for millennia
Jews have given their hearts blood in
Hirsch words for the religion for the
religious idea behind it the Jews knew
it was there eternal mission to become
my quote the blessing of the world and
this is why they had survived until or
they will survive also in the future
until their mission is accomplished and
a messiah finally
at social computing system now Hearst
daring replied to Bruno bar was widely
read and discussed in contemporary
German Jewry
all of the major Jewish journals
academic and popular published details
reviews of Hearst brochure especially
interesting as a critical discussion of
firsts first view that I want to mention
shortly written by the young Hellman
yelenic for a journal called lifts to
blood does audience in 1843 Hammond
yelling like is the brother of others
hearing at the first Kabbalah scholar of
19th century business after zooming
tombs movement Herman is the younger
brother was executed at the age of 26 in
Vienna for his participation in the
revolution but managed to write
something on our subject before that
happened a few years before gay Linux
reviews at the same time a devastating
criticism of powers pamphlet itself and
a praise of first response while a
balanced view of Christianity is
ultimately nothing but the old Orthodox
supersessionism in modern philosophy
logical language Hersh says yelenic was
a true pioneer in a scientific
explanation of the Jewish core of the
Gospels but yelenic is also critical of
what he considered to be Hurst tolerant
position towards Pauline Christianity in
a joint ear view and this is really
interesting that was held by a whole
group of influential German Jewish
theologians in the 19th century and a
leader of this group is a bomb geiger
that you probably know all of you and
this view might be read as the most
radical response that Jews had for
Christine supersessionism
it says basically Christianity itself
has contributed nothing nothing valuable
to the development of Jewish culture
this is what Geiger thought and that was
the young yelling I thought actually and
and wrote you know and pop public he
said is throughout the 19th century
in an indirect inversion of the common
anti-semitic accusation to this end
Judaism as nothing or had nothing
contributed to civilization it was
argued that not only on the field of
religion but also concerning Natural
Sciences and even art everything
revolutional every revolutional
development was ever directed against
the Christian position which stalled
progress and burned its advocate there
was no Jewish art for unique for example
you know D the greatness of God's
Madonna is because it is a beautiful
woman and nodded as a christian icon so
this is the this is an interesting
position in in our field of 19th century
research because usually we read the
opposite that Jewish especially you Jews
reform movement is imitating
Protestantism so here you have the
reform leaders saying there's nothing to
imitate you know they have not
contributed anything to civilization
still in the same year 48 another
prominent Jewish theologian published a
detailed refutation of powers position
towards Judaism this is the leader of
the old Hamburg reformed temple got
Howard's alimony at the time one of the
most senior most famous pulpit rabbis in
Germany although he agreed in most
aspects with the arguments provided by
her a few months earlier Solomon wrote
in the preface to his book against Bower
Hirsch had presented his arguments in a
confused and on the other an
intellectual ambitious way so that he
Salomon solely urged me to restate the
Jewish reply to bars attack and more
popular form and for wider circle of
readers but while most the first
argument indeed reappear in Solomon's
texts there are a few ideas where
Salomon went beyond Hirsch and I want to
refer to them in general where Hirsch
argued with Hagar Salomon argued with
the Bible and even the Talmud is for
Salomon a clear example of the ethical
progress of Judaism after and in the
pendant of Jesus the purpose of the
Talmud was humanized was ID law kind of
a bold claim that Salomon makes you some
will try to prove for several examples
from the time that this is in fact um
Reform Judaism let me find with the
Talmudic sages the Talmud this this is
repeated several times for Solomon's
book was the attempt to counteract the
dead-letter of the Mosaic law so that
the data were not the letter not rule
and exercise his despotic power over the
consciousness this way
I think Salim will not only replied to
the supersession is claim that Judaism
lacked any sign of progress after the
rise of Christianity also the accusation
of the meaninglessness of Talmudic
ritual was warded off if only by
recruiting the Talmudic sages for Reform
Judaism of course after that and great
details are listed the achievements of
Jewish thought for human civilization
throughout the centuries beginning the
final mentioning of course my monitors
medieval philosophers commenters poetess
poets and finally arriving at Mendel's
own whom we called the modern Socrates
but while those Jewish contributions are
indisputable Salomon even defends
Christianity against power returning to
the metaphor of mother and daughter
Salomon tried to explain the relation of
the generations in a more natural way
than Bauer did before him even and this
is what he says even if the daughter is
more attractive than the mother and even
if she had a million more admirers
everything she is came from her mother
Judaism Salomon argued against power
supersessionism can peacefully coexist
with all its daughters and all other
religions her Christian daughter it is
true is not of such mild disposition she
is driven by a conquering temper but
nothing of this can explain the
cluesive the exclusiveness in fact of
the jew-hatred
that Bauer had contributed to
Christianity anti-semitism in in in
Solomon's view is always the product of
intentional straightforward incitement
and not of religious claims to the
absoluteness of one's own truth Jew
hatred must be implanted grafted onto
Christianity it did not grow naturally
out of mere theological reasons whether
it would and I quote here whether it was
taught and preached by inhuman priests
or laypeople by the throne or by the mob
anti-semitism always has rather the most
despised and base motives
Saruman claimed and of God and Christian
substitution theology was only the
fig-leaf
of those claims in his view the the
anti-semite abuse of Christianity as he
calls it was still in full bloom today
now taken over by men who hold
university chairs in philosophy in
history and contrary to the traditional
Christian model of substitution Salamone
now developed his own model of religious
tolerance interestingly though it is
first and foremost Christianity that has
to change before tolerance could come
into effect Christianity must rid of
most birth itself of the intentional
implant the Jew hatred it has if
Christianity is able to emancipate the
juice it will itself be emancipated says
Salamone but as long and I quote again
as long as it wants to rule it will
serve and as long as it seeks salvation
in domination it finds itself in slavery
and of course once both religions walk
hand-in-hand Salomon wrote and long
summary of his book it will become
apparent that not bowers pessimistic
atheism but religious optimism is the
very foundation of peace and freedom not
religion itself as the problem behind
hatred and war in this world Bowers Hey
sublation of religion would mean to heal
the headache by beheading sorry for the
comparison but this is what he said and
I prepared this paper before this became
so the future will bring much more than
a dead piece that is Solomon's
conclusion that will bring the living
freedom of religious cooperation between
Judaism and Christianity with neither
side having to claim superiority in some
way when Jewish thinkers reacted to
Poona bars secular version of
supersessionism they argued in a variety
of ways as we saw what all their
rejections of power have in common
however is the notion of a unique
mission of Judaism to humanity that is
still not fulfilled and cannot be
fulfilled by Christianity at least not
in Christianity his current state this
mission would just with us justify the
existence of Judaism both in the past
and in the future mosaic monotheism had
not only I quote given all civilized
nations and states a moral foundation
and of quote God Salomon monotheistic
Jewish religious doctrine was also the
ideal guidance for a peaceful and
unified humanity in the future whether
some Jewish disputants claimed the
absolute superiority of Judaism over
half pagan Christianity's other others
rather emphasized the influential
Christian contribution to the universal
propagation of Jewish ideas still others
called on Christianity to become aware
of its Jewish essence and live up to it
non of all the people involved in the
discussion would agree with Bauer the
Judaism is an outlived concept of
religion stubbornly capitalized by some
aberrational illusionists who refuse to
accept his exclusive rights of the
daughter religion whether they saw in
Bauer's attack a new moral danger coming
from philosophical atheism or rather the
old language of pristine supersessionism
the debate with Unabomber gave the
Jewish theologian theologians a welcome
opportunity to reason out and locate
and this is probably again for the first
time in Jewish intellectual history
Judaism's precise place within the
intellectual developments of world
history forced by power to justify
Judaism very own role in the modern
world instead of criticizing Christian
irrationalism powers Jewish opponents
began to analyze Jewish religion and
history from the outside of it from a
philosophical point of view and in this
sense I think T this debate is still of
value today
the latter research resulted in his book
roots of anti-semitism by Braille in
2009 he is presently working on the
study of ethnic Jewish thought
structures with early church fathers to
the Holocaust and today he will be
speaking to us on the construction of
the Jews thank you thank you so much so
I will talk not about personal foul but
about F C foul so just to make it clear
the construction of the Jews in 19th
century German Protestantism the case of
cheating in professors Beck and FC about
during my studies I happen to do some
work on the treating in New Testament
professor Kenneth Keaton and his at
least in his early years associate
warteg want man due to the fact that
they were not only expertise but
National Socialists exegetes after my
doctoral dissertation this led to my
study route sociological and semitism
focusing on German Protestant exegesis
from 1750 to 1950 and if anyone wants to
look at it afterwards I have it here
just as we are these theologians were
part of a history and here I focus on
two scholars also in tubing him we're in
the early and mid eighteen hundreds both
Ferdinand Christian both 1792 to 1860
and Johann to be a spec 1804 to 1878
were professors of theology Barr was a
church historian but with a tremendous
scope from New Testament to church
history and systematic theology and more
Beck was a professor of theology much
separated [ __ ] and bow and at first
sight the fact that above favorite Beck
seems pick you
since they belong to the two opposing
streams which still prevail in German
theology Beck's theological profile was
opposite about Beck being the leading
bibley cysts having for example spent
many years of fighting for example D
leftist views Beck's background was an
old villain bag Pietism but his theology
wasn't fully kosher in the Lutheran
environment due to his non forensic view
of justification however he was one of
the most cherished preachers of his time
and was both the key figure in the
teaming in faculty and the head preacher
through critical in the squishy in
tübingen Paul must be regarded one of
the founding fathers of modern exegesis
even though his pit row Jews and Judaism
has much in common with for example
Sandler and Schleiermacher but with bow
the dialectical description of early
Christianity really got a breakthrough
in New Testament studies as part of his
study of early church history formed in
the vein of Hegel and Schelling so we
are on the same ground in in several
ways here Christian history was part of
world history to bow the two worlds of
paganism and Judaism on the verge of
dissolution are becoming a synthesis in
Christianity to bow this movement is
also parallel to a similar political one
which ends up in the Roman Empire a key
part of this analysis is that both
describe a trajectory from particularism
to universalism to bow Jews and Judaism
is the
example of particularism jewish national
character is peculiar and the jews
always maintained this quote/unquote
obstinate dissimilarity from other
peoples as the jews lived in palestine
they were locked into a world of
nationalist and legalism isolated from
other peoples palestinian judaism could
never develop out of his bounds but is
when diaspora judaism meets a certain
form of paganism greek thought that
Judaism is changed into the synthesis
Helenus judaism that the term Hellenism
is highly problematic is another story
but bob is the one to really make this a
major tool of analysis in early
Christian historiography thus Bao is
keen on the contribution of the Greek
philosophical tradition and through the
balloon and sister of Greek culture
Judaism is elevated into something
higher Judaism is then like a miner who
gets mature when meeting Greek salt and
culture the same pattern is there when
bow constructs his narrative of early
Christianity the the Jerusalem church is
Jewish in the narrow sense the more
legalistic Hebrew apostles stayed in
Jerusalem whereas the Greek speaking
deacons
the so called hello nests had a more
spiritual inner worship and brought the
gospel of freedom into the world this is
also true for the Diaspora Jew Paul and
due to the three-year spiritual
condition it is in the Diaspora that
Christianity is thriving if much about
the dialectic has been abandoned this
analysis still sticks with New Testament
scholarship the truth is that Helena
style which I think always you
in in acts 6 and 1 I think also in in in
acts 11 simply means Greek speakers and
doesn't imply any special graces or
freer theology rather I think the
heaviness --tz-- of Jerusalem where the
really Orthodox guys that I come in from
the Diaspora to be in Jerusalem and
worship as close to the temple as
possible my parallel is the people
presence people diaspora Jews present at
the Western Wall and whose dialect may
betray them that they are not actually
from Israel Stevens
sermon in acts 7 marks a breakthrough
with it's about temple criticism
Christianity espouses it must break away
from Judaism and bring about its final
destruction and leisure undergone one
final example is Baus interpretation of
Romans a letter which to him is written
to cut Jewish particularism and his
roots I quote all the apostle develops
in the first eight chapters is the
necessary condition for being able to
cut the Jewish particularism that
opposed the universalism of the Apostle
in a Jewish Christian Church and its
root and the quote both reading of
Romans is unrealistic and coloured by
his strongly ideological glasses
he describes all of his history using
his dis dialectics so that the history
of Judah
and Christianity can be describing the
dichotomies where the Jews or Jewish
Christians never get the upper hand
spirit gospel freedom versus law
spiritual and inward versus outward and
limited higher spontaneous ethics versus
legalism faith versus works Universalist
versus particularism elevated versus
undeveloped in terms of culture and
erudition and spirituality but also
diaspora versus Palestinian Poland vs
Petrin and Hellenistic versus Hebrew and
this can we could go on with this also
to to see how he Dakota Mises the
political situation and in in Germany
using the same opposites so it becomes
kind of a nice list which I have here
the Jew is then in a negative sense the
eternal other and when describing the
symbolic world about Judaism is on the
minus side and Hellenism is on the plus
side thus becoming inherently racist
Jews being narrow particularist
troublemakers who are resisting God's
plans and whose religion must go under
making them an antithesis of everything
which was important for Christianity it
is true that some scholars for example
schleiermacher
are even more brutal in disconnecting
christianity from judaism bhau's
dialectic keeps the thesis elements
the synthesis how Paul is Jewish but his
Jewishness is dissolved and through his
diaspora existence he's elevated into
something higher given this consist
concession to Judaism as playing one
part on the way to freedom still then
light and polyhistor in tübingen
contributed to a negative picture of
Judaism which is fairly unified in this
stream of theology I also have argued
that bow is also constructing the
history of early Christianity to fit his
analysis of the political situation in
his country he refines particularism to
be the big bad move but in visions of
political universalism where the
enormous amount of political units India
Germany should be dissolved into a
liberal national state justice Rome
becomes the political umbrella over the
Mediterranean world
and now to Beck Beck's view of Jews and
Judaism is almost opposite where as
bowel so Jews and Judaism as
representing a superseded stage in the
trajectory toward the winning synthesis
Beck had an organic view of the
relationship between Christianity and
Judaism in contrast to Baus Beck's
spiritual world history pivots around
Abraham and Israel and he describes
history as an organic salvation history
with the seed in Abraham and the crown
in Christ a great a grand monarchical
world story the general description of
Jews and Judaism is almost entirely
positive the Jewish people are God's
covenant people and Israel is I quote
the physical carrier of the stem of
Grace and quote the to law is a positive
force a token of the special
relationship between God and the people
and superior to any other legislation
but it is in the connection with the law
that he has one of the few negative
descriptions of Jews before they receive
the law they were an obstinate
uncultivated people but the lor
discipline them which means that Jews
under the law are okay in his thinking
the law is then something positive as
long as it doesn't lead to legalism
faith is the foundation of for salvation
but instead of an opposition of law and
faith there is a sequence both in the
individual Ordo salutis and that of
mankind which are parallel as noted to
bow particularism and narrow nationalism
are negative and typical of Jews in Beck
however there is a certain positive
particularism since the family of
Abraham is absolutely instrumental in
bringing salvation what is national is
positive and it's God himself that
grants the form enormous but nation with
the possession of a land even Jewish
national pride which is you know
something which is used so much in the
literature even I mean in in the modern
commentaries we were hearing about today
even Jewish quote unquote national pride
is positive I quote the pride in being
God's people and it rests primarily on
their objective precedence and quote he
contends the organic view is illustrated
by his growing this growing and
developing tree with Abrahamic roots and
in this organic you view continuity
instead of discontinuity is natural
history is a harmonic sing with no
radical cuts no leaving behind a former
stages but rather a unified flow
according to God's
economy or grace there is universalism
but different from from vows
the latter abandons all particular isms
for a synthetic universalism bex
universalism is rooted in and realized
through a particular history of a people
a family a land and an individual Christ
who not only is the Messiah of the Jews
but I quote the original organic head of
the world system end quote
this is where Paul sees national Judaism
as the main hindrance on Christian and
his path to becoming a world historical
reality and here they are absolutely
opposite them also in his commentary to
Roman's becky's majoring on the Jews and
in fact this argument is developed in
critical dialogue with bow and that's a
bit fascinating too to read that
commentary and see how is actually
disputing with his colleague and friend
in the same town so in contrast to him
Beck rejects that Romans has any
particular criticism of Judaism or
Jewish Christianity instead
Peck's is a deep continuity between the
two through the Old Testament Christians
he says were spiritually connected to
Judaism an early through the Old
Testament it says Christians were
spiritually connected to Judaism and
early Christianity in Rome was so Jewish
that people could mistake them for Jews
this is quite a modern view of
I'm an early Christianity in Rome now as
you know I have chosen this intriguing
interaction between two colleagues in
beautiful TV to exempt exemplify roughly
two positions on Jews and Judaism in
19th century German Protestantism some
general observations can be made there
is no doubt that the views of Jews and
Judaism was conditioned by the actual
history of the German Lander during this
period both streams of both political
universalism emancipation national unity
of the greater Germany and democracy are
parallel to his analysis of early
Christianity whereas Beck seemingly was
more at home in the monarchical system
our associates Jews and Judaism will to
him negative things as aristocracy
theocracy and Roman Catholicism Beck
associates Christ with Abraham Moses and
regards theocracy as something positive
if one constructive use of Jews and
Judaism in a graphic symbolic universe
with in burgers terms the sacred canopy
at the top and it's opposite to the
bottom I know it's simple or perhaps
even simplistic but it's vivid Beck
would place symbols if we take the
sacred canopy as the positive side here
they could place symbols as Abraham
Judaism Israel law even circumcision on
the sacred canopy and that surprising
compared with almost every other
Christian author whereas Bar would do
the opposite to him words as freedom
from the law
Billy dawn and hypotonic ethos would be
on the sacred canopy but Jews Judaism
law Palestinian Jewish Christianity
would be at the bottom putting this in
the context of troubling legacies anti
dualism in
with eNOS aftermath the two teaming and
professors are each part of a post in
paradigms I know that two
black-and-white descriptions can be seem
overly simplistic and I will come to the
complexities but still we can see them
really ending up in two different
paradigms bow adheres to the typical
Enlightenment picture or alignment
oriented research tradition and baked to
the salvation historical tradition Jews
and Judaism are essential to the
salvation historical parody but not
necessarily to the Enlightenment
oriented the theologian saw modernity if
they welcome modernity or fought it
paved the way for later generations
understand towards Jews Jews and Judaism
the final semitism opiate is figures
like back before him tall Luke and after
him fans the elite and Haman stark made
them take a public stand against for
example the recurring blood libels that
became a big problem to the german
jewish public at the same time as they
had profound interest as they had
profound interest in the missions to
Israel which was no success among German
Jewry at all
both the alicia's truck were publicly
recognized by German Jewry for their
contributions nevertheless Levinson is
partly right in pointing to their allo
Semitism solidarity with Jews could be
combined with comments like that Jews
are obstinate or proud as we will see in
a later TV group such a negative
attitude to Jews and Judaism would
evil fruit enlightenment oriented use of
views of Jews and Judaism could be
programmatically tolerant we have for
example that up via Ferran against
anti-semitism which was liberal at its
foundation
however liberal could mean other things
that we think for example the liberal
professor who the functionalist could
say that I quote when the Jews will give
up their distinctiveness we shall
witness the final consummation of
emancipation and quote this is what we
are calling the Janos face of the
Enlightenment
however political anti-semitism grew
impiety sift circles with a both period
of study who combines the full list of
anti-jewish stereotypes with a I quote
unquote pious and conservative stance
his tradition is partly imported into
other influential another inferential
face of tübingen theological history
that of adult slaughter who thought
highly of structure Turkey had another
admirer as well Adolf Hitler who admired
Turkish success in managing
anti-semitism a popular movement during
national socialist times the pitcher is
complex as well both cannot keep silent
about the gaunt man the most well known
figures in national socialist exegesis
came from this tubing and think tank of
the late 1920s and early 1930s Keita
with roots in five Semitic Piatt ism
nevertheless be
national-socialist and a programmatic
anti-semite but halted when he came to
rejecting the Hebrew Bible the text of
which his famous father had edited and
when I read learnt every once upon a
time it was from from Keith Alvin
Kittles who loved kittens edition or he
also halted well it was about making
Jesus an area which is impossible to
kita
he actually had done a pioneer called
the pioneer work for the understanding
of the Palestinian Jewish roots of early
Christianity don't man on the other hand
both the message of and indeed became
achieve ideologist of the dosha crystal
to whom it was imperative to both
abandon the Old Testament and to argue
that Jesus was an area to those do so he
had to adapt more liberal positions
torture Christian at large was more
liberal when it came to the exegesis of
the New Testament something which made
it easier to combine their theology with
their political ideology eventually
joint mangoes for in his NASA fide
theology I quote listen to this when the
Germans stand in this struggle for
hereditary soundness and uprightness of
life the rice has really come among them
and his ruler is the field this is
written by the New Testament professor
India now one may conclude that ideas
like the continuity between Judaism and
Christianity the essentiality of the
Hebrew Bible for Christian theology and
the Jewishness of Jesus and early
Christianity belong to those things
which put a halt to the worst troubling
legacies
but even holding to them a world leading
scholar
ketta could be an anti-semite this shows
at the end of the day it is a choice
everyone has to make between love or
hate a firm belief in the absolute
dignity of humanity which is a cynic
were known in Jewish Christian tradition
is the only thing that guarantees the
protection of every woman thank you very
much so this session is seen our
conversation migrated summarily from
antiquity to modernity in our neglect I
think of the time intervening is not
unwarranted or not unjustifiable because
little of what Christian intellectuals
had to say about Jews and Judaism during
the time intervening let's say the
Middle Ages to the time of the
Enlightenment actually improved upon the
sordid polemics of the church's
formative age in contrast the
developments discussed by doctors
Gardner and Koehler signaled the
emergence of a new kind of polemic that
would by the end of the 19th century
acquired the notorious name
anti-semitism now as a scholar of
antiquity I often find myself at odds to
see modern anti-semitism as a modern
invention so much as I see it as a move
to breathe new life into an old and
familiar prejudice and so on what
follows I'll briefly respond to doctors
GERD Mara and Koehler by explaining what
I believe on the one hand Ferdinand
Christian dower and on the other hand
Bruno Bauer contributed to this movement
in respect to their respective
adaptations
the classical Christian supersession its
argument considering really whether it's
fair to characterize what they had to
say about that subject as new in view of
the intellectual traditions which they
drew now at the heart of both their
accounts of Judaism was the distinction
between the alleged particularism of the
Jew and the contrasting universalism of
his non-jewish counterpart in respect or
I should say in the writings of FC bauer
the distinction was between Jew and
Christian in the work of Bruno Bauer the
distinction was between the particular
Jews and Christian on one hand and the
universal that that was his Republican
ideal in any way in any account let us
take a moment to parse these terms
particular and universal the play so
heavily in their works conventional
wisdom would have it that Jesus preached
a gospel of universal significance and
as much as his promise of eschatological
salvation applied to all peoples or as
Jesus himself puts it in Gospel of
Matthew he wished to make disciples of
all nations that missionary premise set
his sense of God's mercy against a
classical Jewish doctrine the promised
deliverance only to the nation of Israel
that is to the Jews while offering no
guarantees regarding the fates of other
nations Jesus's first disciples thereby
appreciated what other Jews of their day
did not namely that their Messiah their
Christ rejected the distinction between
Israel and the Gentiles that had been
written into their scriptures and
thereby upon the Jewish faith the rest
of the Jews meanwhile continue to
operate on the misguided premise that
they would attain salvation by keeping
to the outdated rules and regulations
laid exclusively upon their ancestors
and not the ancestors of other nations
at Mount Sinai a very long time ago so
at the heart of the philosophical
distinction between Christian
universalism and Jewish particularism
why is the idea that Jesus rejected
Judaism for being too focused on the
soteriological needs of the Jews and not
focused enough on the needs of humanity
at large but that reading of the gah
is hardly intuitive permit me to
elaborate scholars since FC Bao are
generally have recognized the Apostle
Paul was the first to discern in the
teachings of Jesus his unique concern
for the nation's for the Gentiles
thereby distinguishing his own
eschatological outlook and thereby the
eschatological outlook I should say of
Jesus and thereby of the of the
Christian collective distinguishing that
outlook from that of his fellow Jews and
Paul articulates this theory most
clearly most concisely in his letter to
the Galatians Paul the Apostle to the
Gentiles wrote this short missive in
response to a report that's certain of
his constituents in the region of
Galatia in what is today a central
turkey had been visited by other
apostles other messengers of Jesus who
had encouraged them to practice the law
of the Jews that is to adhere to
legislation of the Torah to this Paul
took offense in as much as he had told
them that they as Gentiles did not need
to practice the Jewish law in order to
win God's favor in advance of his
impending final judgment they said Paul
had only to adhere to the ethical
teachings of Jesus in order to partake
of God's covenant with Israel now I am
of course simplifying the circumstances
of Paul's correspondence with the
Galatian Church is quite a bit and you
can drill me on that later but that will
be enough to allow me to make my point
proceeding to explain why the Gentiles
do not have to submit to the legislation
of the Torah
Paul alludes to an argument an abraded
elsewhere in his writings whereby he
submits that the law of the Jews demands
a standard of righteousness impossible
for normal human beings to meet the
Torah and his estimation was no reward
for Israel's faith it was a sentence for
their infidelity a yoke laid upon the
necks of God's chosen people on account
of their predilection for sin God says
Paul imposed upon and imposed his law
that is upon the Jews as a preventative
measure or as he puts it a pedagogue to
keep them in line with his will against
their natural instincts but that
precaution Paul now explains is no
longer necessary having given himself as
a sacrifice of atonement Jesus
had absolved Israel of sin the
everlasting partnership between God and
His people was thus restored to its
original state of pure faith of kisses
in Greek consequently Paul asserts the
covenantal privileges once reserved for
those bound by the Jewish law were now
available to all individuals who elected
to practice that faith that is the faith
of Jesus to be baptized or to use Paul's
language immersed in the Messiah no
longer relevant were the distinctions
between Jew and Greek slave and free
even male and female that stood to
divide or separate the worshipers of God
Jesus he asserts that joined all of
humanity and common cause with one
another now to be clear Paul says
nothing here about universalism or
particularism his point is simply that
the law of the Jews was meant only for
the Jews and only until the advent of
the Messiah whereas the teachings of
Jesus the teachings of the Messiah were
meant for everybody and forevermore it
would take Paul's interpreters to read
his words to connote in a qualitative
contrast between his Christianity and
the Judaism that he appeared to indict
now of course Paul would not have
recognized himself as a Christian but as
the religious movement that he
stimulated grew estranged from its
Jewish roots the rhetorical context of
the Apostles account of the Jewish law
was lost on readers apt to see Paul as
the Christian par excellence his
critique of the Torah was thereby
received as an indictment of the
misguided convictions of all who chose
to adhere to its legislation the Jews in
other words appeared to Paul's readers
to spurn the Apostles conviction that
Jesus had dissolved the ethnic
categories traditionally understood to
distinguish them the Jews from the
Gentiles and indeed by the second
century Christian thinkers had begun to
style their collective enterprise is a
new ethnos a third race neither Jewish
nor Greek and United not by the bonds of
nationhood but by the bonds of faith the
apostle to the Gentiles thus inspired
Christians to see themselves in terms
exclusive of Judaism and its attendant
ethnic rhetoric Christianity in short
became Universal and Judaism particular
because Jesus
was thought to have made it so I could
say more about the tendentious logic and
cultural misperceptions at play here but
I do not wish to get sidetracked
I mean merely to point out that the
distinction between the universal in the
particular submitted in various ways by
FC Bauer and by Bruno Bauer as a
rational assumption was predicated on
the fundamentally irrational notion that
the birth of Christianity somehow
diminished the viability of Judaism as a
religion of enduring worth now that's
not to say that the premise of bringing
the gospel to the Gentiles was devoid of
reason what was irrational was the
discourse on Christian identity that
arose from that missionary venture a
discourse predicated on the notion that
the Jews were bound by the refusal of
the gospel to remain forever oppressed
by an archaic code of law incompatible
with the liberating doctrine espoused by
Jesus Christ thus within decades of
Christianity's birth to be a Christian
in the minds of many and I would contend
most who claimed that name of Christian
demanded the construction of the Jew as
an intellectual inferior and a social
malcontent somebody who didn't want to
get with the program and in time that
became the dominant Christian truth of
Judaism whereby it would proceed for
centuries to inform attitudes toward the
Jews amongst those beholden to the
Christian intellectual tradition that
tradition of course evolved in the
modern age into what we now know as the
Western tradition in part by disowning
some of its more obviously problematic
asuma logical foundations yet the
impression of judaism as an obsolete
morally recidivist mode of thought
remained fixed in the minds of those
Western thinkers up to see the Jew
primarily as a Christian antic type
defined by his congenital disregard for
those not belonging to his strange and
functionally extinct ethnic group all of
which lead me leads me to the following
conclusions for theologian FC Bauer the
stubborn slavish mentality of the Jew
kept him from achieving the humanity of
the enlightened Christian for the
political theorist Bruno Bauer that you
could
that pinnacle of consciousness but only
by disavowing his Judaism each on his
own succumbed to the fallacy of a
cultural stereotype rooted in the
ancient theological conceit of
supersessionism in other words when it
came to resent in Jews these men did not
reinvent the wheel they merely developed
more sophisticated ways to describe its
mechanism to express in scientific terms
the conventional wisdom of generations
past if therefore one is to trace the
development of the modern pseudoscience
of anti-semitism to the effort of such
scholars and other men of their
generation it bares asking once again
what precisely was new about their
attitudes toward the Jews and what was
old nearly made to seem new I do not
imagine that that is a question with a
straightforward answer as I have
proposed here but I hope to have shown
that searching our preconceptions about
the history and nature of anti-semitism
stands to reveal more unknown settling
truths about its intellectual
underpinnings than even its putative
authors new thank you
right we have about eight nine minutes
for questions so I'm gonna open it to
the floor and we're gonna use this
standing mic over here and be wonderful
next when you ask a question you do by
densify yourself you don't want to take
the first
and I'll but particularly to you
professor Garin Mar I'm wondering about
the connection between what I would call
the heretical imagination that's
occurring in systematic and historical
theology and Bauer and the exegetical
direction in anti-semitism that one
himself as I'm sure you know saw a very
close connection between contemporary
liberal Protestantism and the heretical
movements have known Dennis Gnosticism I
know it's a very contentious term so
much so that his friend and colleague
that was a low thought Bauer should just
admit as I think he thought modern
Protestantism was not Christianity in a
classical sense if anything it was a
kind of return to ancient heresies and
so I wonder particularly in contrast
with a back part of a much more orthodox
pietistic tradition is there any
connection between the revival of a deep
attraction to her Etica forms of
Christianity arguably endemic to
Protestantism the way it provides Arian
isn't very quickly Milton and other
thinkers and then becomes the basis of
Unitarianism and rationalism and then is
developed very systematically in German
biblical studies in systematic theology
is there a connection between this kind
of highly intellectual interpretation of
Christianity the appeal to heresy and
then a very radically intellectually
systematized anti-semitism thank you I
think you can say I don't know if I can
say so much about Becky in this
connection when it comes to bow he
definitely has a crash for for the grief
of course as we say for the the Platonic
philosophy and so on but also for
Gnosticism I mean he has is maybe one of
the few Christian
authors who really wrote something very
very positive about Gnosticism so but
then is the question and I cannot answer
that in detail how informed he is how
DEP has gone into analysis Oh
Gnosticism I mean we have to understand
that of course this is not the
Gnosticism we know after the nag hammadi
findings because they were they were
really I mean they were really
revolutionizing our whole understanding
of Gnosticism then it would rather than
be the the the heretical Gnosticism of
apologies and of course he was well
aware of all of that debate and well
aware of all of those descriptions and
perhaps he even then was dependent on
the picture the apologies picture of
Gnosticism and still took it to himself
so I think this was really constructing
over like an alternative universe so to
say say liberal enlightened and
if you offer - yes one favorite German
that is elevated and open there is a
some kind of of spirituality which is
not bound to the to the ritual to the
historical than definitely not do
anything Jewish which he would find them
in a very particular bound to certain
rituals certain form certain phase etc
certain functions but something which
was elevated and we would say maybe a
bit Spacey where we when we study
Gnosticism through the through the
apologies so definitely he has a he has
a blessed for this when it comes to back
I don't know but basically back would
stick to his Bible because back is
biblical and he constructs his whole
world thought world with this big epic
reading of the Bible as a unit with as I
said movement from Abraham to Christ as
a problem I don't know if this helps but
thank you very much my question is for
Prichard professor Kohler my name is
Mike nice to meet you
I have a question with respect to you
the influence in the presences of
Spinoza and Mendel zone in the 19th
century and I know this is a bit
complicated right because like Spinoza
had the kind of public and a private
profile for example in
eighteenth-century Hamburg but I'm
curious about with respect to the pier
that he presented upon the more public
reception and who were the public
readers of Spinoza and also of Mendoza
formalism it's very easy because he is
mostly rejected I mean he is recognized
as the pioneering figure of modern
Jewish thought but his solution for you
know this very question they all talk
about all the time how could you days
and be justified in modernity how can we
you know find a reason for the
you know further existence of Judaism
are you know after emancipation after
everything particular doesn't play any
role anymore the solution that
Mendelssohn found in his famous book
Jerusalem is almost entirely rejected by
all Jewish thinkers which pin also it's
it's quite difficult and as no there's
no one answer no no no simple answer and
and you even have you know people
changing their minds about Spinoza's
contribution to you know what would be a
new to your theology but also you know
in a general philosophy at all - I have
a figure like ham on corn you know they
may be the most towering Jewish
philosopher you know the turn of the
20th century who is really actually
changing his mind in a useful article
from from the 1870s he's praising
Spinoza and then even you know pantheist
manner and then in his later works
Herman Cohen is rejecting him as the ark
enemy of everything that is Jewish
because he's deterministic he is not an
idealist and pantheism is seen to be
worse than polity is imagining so so for
Spinoza that that it's very difficult
but also it's not very it's towards the
end it's not exactly the time I was
talking about that you have big spin
also debates you know this is
Mendelssohn has this problem because
he's you know it's his friend blessing
is accused of being spin assist when you
notice all and and there's not much
discussion and then only only at the end
of the of the 19th century it's been
also comes up again as a controversial
figure where Jewish thinkers could not
exactly decide which try to take so what
Madison is absolutely clear and this is
one of us on my to-do list you know to
write an article by Magnuson reception
in 19th century Jewish reformed theology
because this is very interesting how
they accept them on the one side as the
one you know the breakthrough figure you
know the the first true you think I
would ever think about this question
what is the exact place of Judaism
within universal theology
not you know not polemically you know he
is of course forced to do that it's not
it's not his own decision but once
forced he's doing this but this is the
one side and on the other side the
solution he founds or the answer he
gives on this question is completely
rejected by every reform thinking and as
a lot of material their books articles
in 19th century Jewish theology on men
on men and Sun that has no researcher
ever touch this is a question for Josh
burns I was wondering to what extent you
feel that particularly Christian forms
of anti Judaism ancient ones things like
supersessionism are informed by the
sentiments that we were hearing about in
the first session from Greek and Roman
authors whether you think that there's a
strong relationship there and then also
whether you would consider the advent of
Christianity to also be sort of a new
platform for those sentiments to be
expressed in the same way as a sort of
philosophical innovations Aventis
yes I have my my doubts about the
connection between the well women what
we might or might not called the Judea
phobic motifs we've heard about earlier
and the rise of Theological
anti-semitism what strikes me and what
is what a strike to a number of scholars
who have written about in proposed Judea
phobia as a distinct type of ethnic bias
in antiquity is that some of the charges
such as those that Professor Esau
mentioned this morning about misanthropy
peculiarities they escaped me at the
moment that they don't really speak to
theological concerns they speak to
racial or ethnic concerns I think that
to to posit a link between the sort of
racial bias that arose really beginning
in the 17th century following the
introduction of Hebraic and Judaic
scholarship to the Protestant Academy
that sort of what I call before pseudo
scientific anti-semitism couched in
terms of racial theory and cultural
theory I don't really see a connection a
clear connection between that kind of
talk and the works of Tacitus and
juvenile and so forth although certainly
the professors who first devises idea
simulations they were theologians one
assumes that they were familiar with
some classical sources although they
certainly didn't rely on those sources
in their production of ethnographic
studies of Jews in contemporary Europe